was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
sondern ein video ich hoffe natürlich
geht es gut deutlicher mega bock dass
jetzt endlich durchzuziehen wir haben
gerade 22 uhr aber ich konnte einfach
nicht mehr warten ja ich bin einfach
neugierig haben heute mal wieder amazon
retouren allerdings nicht so wie sonst
also ich glaube dass heute wirklich mit
abstand der beste part will sting ist
einfach sonst habe ich immer willkürlich
so gekauft und oftmals war es halt auch
einfach schon so waren die schon an
verschiedenen stationen war und dann war
es halt einfach nicht mehr so gut ich
bin durch zufall in kontakt geraten der
hat ganz viel amazon retouren ware hab
mir auch listen geschick und das ist
alles ungeöffnet sich einkauft ich habe
fast 1000 euro bezahlt für dieses paket
und da ist ware im wert von über 5000
euro drauf natürlich wird nicht alles
einwandfrei funktionieren aber ich denke
dass es sich trotzdem sehr lohnen wird
ich bin heute morgen um acht uhr
losgefahren deswegen vielleicht hier mal
kurz ein paar sequenzen ich hab nämlich
heute morgen kleinen block gemacht guten
morgen ich bin hier gerade in bad
oeynhausen oder so und ich kaufte sie
ein paar ebay amazon retouren so etwas
geht halbe stunde gefahren ging
eigentlich und zwar habe ich bei ebay
kleinanzeigen die man gefunden der
eigentlich ganz neiße amazon retouren
paletten hat und dafür jetzt einfach mal
hin kauf gemacht und ich hoffe es geht
so leute was geht war es ein gesagt ich
war gerade bei den kollegen ganz
natürlich auch leute heute morgen schon
fleißig hat ihr was abgeholt da sollen
6000 euro waren mir drin sein ich bin
gespannt direkt von amazon ich habe
eigentlich mit drei kartons gerechnet
jetzt ist es nur einer geworden macht
aber auch sinn weil so schwer ist die
ware nicht oder es sind eigentlich eher
kleinere sachen soweit ich weiß ich bin
eigentlich guter dinge dass sich das
lohnen wird aber genau kann ich so nicht
einschätzen ich zeige euch gleich mal
den karton bis gleich okay leute die ich
habe jetzt also das liegt auf jeden fall
über 30 kilo hab mir jetzt mal eine ecke
ein bisschen ist man jetzt noch das
paket das ist ja scheiße ich muss
fairerweise sagen ich habe mir vor
listen angeschaut und ich habe nur das
gekauft wo ich bin überzeugt dass ich
damit halt wirklich so gesehen profit
machen kann oder das ist nicht einfach
für mich lohnt ich kann es euch hier mal
ein ich habe 850 brutto gezahlt und ja
insgesamt kann man hier wohl fünf
herausholen aber das wird nicht klappen
aber wenn ich es nur verdoppelt ist ja
auch in ordnung und 5000 euro ist ja
auch eine menge geld also ich bin super
gespannt man denkt sich immer abends
ganz entspannt noch ein video aufnehmen
und dann geht es los ich habe meinen
stativ zu hause vergessen ihr müsst euch
mal anschauen wie unprofessionell dass
hier aussieht dann finde ich meinen
scheiß cuttermesser nicht ich kann euch
direkt sagen wenn das gut ist dann werde
ich da auch noch noch teurer einkauf
also der hat auch paletten
beziehungsweise kartons mit den 20.000
euro warenwert drin kann man dann auch
immer aus tekken und ihr könnt euch
freuen weil in zukunft kommen noch
einige wirklich coole projekte auf euch
zu und yahoo ihr könnt euch nicht
vorstellen wie beruhigend dass gerade
für mich ist es ist das allererste mal
dass ich eine amazon- retouren palette
öffne und ich jede marke kennedy mir
entgegenkommt wir haben hier keine milch
palette es ist alles so geriet also
keine smartphones nichts von apple muss
ich schon mal vorweg sagen trotzdem
geile sachen brown church die oral-b was
ist das hier biblis okay leute ganz
kurzen einblick den ich jetzt hatte bum
bum bum ok und reicht schon ihr habt
euch mal mein setup ist einfach es ist
bodenlos okay leute wir starten einfach
mal was haben wir hier war damals ein
bisschen rüber als erstes haben wir hier
eine oral b zahnbürste series 7 ist ganz
neues elektrische zahnbürsten von oral b
gern mal 100 euro schauen wir mal ob ich
schon jemanden münchen hatte oder nicht
nein das sieht doch stabil aus super
akku schon jetzt seien aber ich glaube
der zustand ist in ordnung kann man auf
jeden fall rein theoretisch
weiterverkauf oder vielleicht werde ich
auch selber benutzen weil ihr könnt euch
nicht vorstellen wie man eine zahnbürste
grad aussieht das ist schon mal wild
also die kostet neuer 465 euro und ja
ich hab ich ja gesagt ich hab' 850 foto
bezahlt ich bin mal gespannt ob wir die
5te knacken werden also halt mit den
neupreis aber naja ok die nächste oral b
wir machen einfach erst mal direkt die
langweiligen sachen und dann geht es
gleich schnell weiter oh gott einfach
mit zahnpasta noch bei der ok das ist
halt direkt schon scheiße dass richter
auch richtig nach zahnpasta ist das
ekelhaft man wieso testet man diese
scheiße denn und schickt sie dann zurück
ehrlich leute haben diese menschen kein
gewissen das kann man doch nicht
weiterverkaufen dann testen oder schickt
wenigstens hygienisch vernünftig zurück
und nicht so machen das ist aber ach so
ja ja okay ich weiß dass ein
pulsmessgerät von beurer die sind auch
eigentlich teuer schauen wir mal ob das
angeht ach so auch hier müssen batterien
rainha wird denke ich funktionieren so
also kommt drauf an welches es ist aber
bm 54 na gut ist jetzt nicht so bild 54
euro im internet aber weil er das mal
zurück hier rein schaue ich mir später
noch mal in ruhe an oder vielleicht auch
nicht weil das ist ja so günstig das
lohnt sich erkannt einmal eine gute
ballette und direkt abgehobene alex wir
machen mal hier mit weiter wir haben wir
auf jeden fall einige rasierer jetzt
natürlich nicht so mega fertig sind aber
wir schauen wir uns mal an wenigstens
vernünftig eingepackt ja das sieht doch
auch top aus akku leer kann man auf
jeden fall mitarbeiten möchte ganz
komischer geruch auch der damit kommt
aber naja die muss kurz direkt checken
ich mache es noch am anfang dass ich
direkt die preise jacky irgendwann ist
mir das egal aber auch mal leute hier
steht drauf liquidation liquidation
heißt liquidation aha da gibt es nämlich
auch eine seite in amerika wo man total
liquidation okay das steht für auflösung
oder beseitigung verflüssigung oder
löschungen keine ahnung anscheinend ot
irgendwie vielleicht nun einmal sind fbi
verkäufer aufgelöst wobei es eigentlich
keinen sinn macht weil das ist ja immer
in philipps okay der kostet 66 noch mal
gut wenn wir diese langweiligen teilen
die haben wir dann noch ein rasierer das
ist so ein ähnlicher der ist vielleicht
ja ähnlich teuer keinen plan und dann
haben wir noch ein rasierer okay der
sieht schon ein bisschen teurer aus
panasonic trd g8 panasonic ja also eins
zwei drei vier leute ist einfach so
entspannt das so schön zu sehen dass das
alles hier tolle marken waren ich habe
ihnen 60 euro die kosten ungefähr 60 so
langweilig ok haben wir jetzt mal zu
sachen für unsere mädels ich weiß doch
mädels was ihr feiert und zwar geht die
das ist doch diese marke die jedes
mädchen haben will ich habe irgendwann
mal ein gewinnspiel gemacht und da sei
er ausgerastet
steding und ich wusste nicht mehr weiter
ding ist ich habe immer gesagt das ist
einloggen oder lockenwickler oder was
auch immer weil die dinger sind auch
echt teuer ist das so aussehen oder ist
das richte
die fdk ja damit macht man sich ihre
schicke löckchen in die haare oder in
die playoffs ein bisschen drüber schauen
wir mal ob das ding funktioniert oder
explodiert
ja gott mal an mit das heiß hier ne yo
ist ganz schön heiß schon ja perfekt
funktioniert riecht ein bisschen
verbrannt aber das muss ja so nett die
fdk 140 euro weiter geht's mit dem was
sieht hier noch gut 17 rasierer rasieren
geht über studieren hell macht ja keinen
sinn blick wie dacian hier haben wir die
nächste liquidation und wir haben ja
schon erfahren die creation sachen sind
immer ganz gut also hier ist der nächste
amazon karton der noch ganz frisch etwas
ist das ist die frage das sieht doch
schon gut uns wir haben wieder cage die
un das jetzt aber einen patch die
glätteisen da bin ich mir sicher
sicherlich viel wert ich werde am ende
eine auflistung machen und euch einmal
zeigen was das so alles wehrte sich
werde auch alles einmal checken wach
mitarbeiter hiermit das ist ein philips
haarentfernung leute scheiße live wirkt
dieses ding christsein wir fast 500 euro
diese philips club wie klingt das so als
wäre das ein bisschen defekt also wenn
das funktioniert okay jetzt auch noch so
eine karte mit buy das ist ja schon mal
will das ist auf jeden fall schon mal
benutzt worden wo alter kasse damit
hätte ich wirklich schon einiges raus
haben schon gehe einfach an und war sie
vernünftig oder was auch immer können
sollst ja verschiedene stufen also es
funktioniert es ist halt schon wirklich
so ein bisschen benutzt haben hier ganz
gut sehen paar gebrauchsspuren aber
trotzdem wenn ich da noch 200 bekomme ja
auch okay zwei verschiedene aufsätze
sind sogar mit ball wunderbar wenn es so
weiter geht also ich hab euch ja schon
vorgewarnt hier ist halt alles nur
hygiene drogerie pipapo drin erfüllt von
remington und remington ist doch eine
stabile marke oder weil ein kumpel von
mir der hat sich glaube ich einen koffer
geholt von remington und der koffer war
steuer die machen gar keinen kopf wie
heißt denn diese marke von den teuren
koffern remington füllen was kostet ein
remington für nicht erwähnenswert
tatsächlich der nächste rasierer von war
das ist jetzt die erste marke die ich
nicht kenne ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen
ich hätte da jetzt auch lieber ein
anderes produkt rausgefischt aber ich
habe eben keine wahl
betreut wird sich weiter geht's mit der
nächsten zahnbürste von oral-b das
scheint eine premium edition zu sein es
ist halt wirklich alles retour also was
heißt gut das war mir klar dass alles
retour ist aber alles wurde schon mal
aufgemacht und es gibt ja trotzdem auch
retouren ware die noch nicht geöffnet
war oder die ich halte den paketen
vorfinden wo man sieht okay das noch
gespeist haben wir hier den nächsten
braun rasierer nächsten braun rasierer
traunsee gp9 flex der ist aber für
ladies hier kannst du wieder haare mit
entfernen achselhaare warum auch nicht
muss ich sagen ich weiß nicht wie jene
artikeln ob man sich halt schnell
weiterverkauft bekommen keine ahnung
kenne ich mich jetzt noch nicht so mit
aus sie haben wir noch ein paar mehr
amazon pakete 13 34
die mache ich einfach am ende auch hier
noch eins ich glaube nämlich dass in den
paketen überall richtig premium sachen
drin sind doch mal oral-b weiter das ist
ja so eine richtige station irgendwie
erinnert mich das wenn ich das so
anschaue ein astronaut und guck mal hier
saalekreis man das kann man vielleicht
auch im all einsetzen bald überall auch
im all
ok dann sehe ich hier schon haben wir
die nächsten produkte von george takei
gold professional advance tyler und da
bin ich mir sicher dass dingen das
kostet dich nur 100 euro professional
advanced seiler gold 175 euro 170 euro
waren die dinger nicht früher mal teurer
ich glaube dieses gewinnspiel für euch
da habe ich für 600 euro oder so da
irgendwas eingekauft aber ist auch egal
weil hier haben wir von remington ok
heming ist ja quatsch also remington
haben wir mittlerweile erfahren also ist
ja absolut unangenehm dass auszupacken
ein gut dann haben wir hier noch
babyblues sagt mir auch was kann ich
leider nicht sagen ob ich die marke
jetzt toll finden soll aber ich glaube
die dinger sind auch nicht günstig wie
wahlstedt liquidation draufhat 80 euro
auf amazon okay dann haben wir hier den
nächsten biblis das weiß jeder zehnte
rasierer dann haben wir hier noch einen
rasierer es ist ein high end ferner von
ja ist ja auch langweilig jetzt haben
wir schon genug vom gesehen ich will
euch das gar nicht mehr zeigen ich
glaube ich muss bei dem typen wirklich
die smartphone ware auch kaufen dass wir
der ultra bild also dann heißt das video
zwar ich habe für 3000 euro amazon
retouren im wert von 15.000 euro gekauft
aber ist ja auch egal war man muss halt
schon ein bisschen geld ausgeben wenn
ihr darauf bock habt leute dann zerstört
mal den like button was haben wir hier
noch beließ team italia und halt noch
ein braun epilepsie rottschäfer
epilepsie
asthma das so und dann ist halt auch das
paket leider schon leer aber ist gar
nicht so schlimm weil ich habe ja noch
ein bisschen was also hier haben wir ja
noch ein paar kleine kartons da bin ich
jetzt mal gespannt weil wenn ich das
jetzt so überschlagen ich denke da kommt
man vielleicht so neuwert auf 3000 nicht
ganz wir müssen jetzt eigentlich noch
stabile sachen drin sein die ja wieder
ein scheiß rasierer aber neu ist auch
eine retoure gott vielleicht
unterschätzt sich ja auch einfach diesen
wert von den frauen rasierern beauty set
neuen flex
181 euro und das ist mittlerweile glaube
ich schon das fünfte set na ja also ich
hab so ein gefühl dass hier keinen
rasierer drin sein wird sondern es ist
ein fan von war lehrer war lehrer
sogar das ist nicht nur ein föhn das ist
ein jet wichtiger denn ok dann setze ich
jetzt aber mal auf diese pakete hier
weil je kleiner desto teurer ich weiß
wovon ich rede hat also das kann es ja
direkt in müll schmeißen philips
rasierer aber komplett demoliert ich
habe auf der liste zwei sachen gesehen
die über 400 euro neue kosten sollen
deswegen wundert nicht gerade wo die
sind oder ob ich halt irgendwas total
falsch einschätze irgend eine station
für eine elektrische zahnbürste auch
schwierig also wenn die hälfte von den
sachen defekt ist dann wird das
schwierig alles man guckt man hier auch
benutzte zahnbürsten das hab ich mir
jetzt irgendwie anders vorgestellt dass
ich jetzt noch ein paar banger rausholen
aber soll wohl nicht so sein letztes
paket irgendeinen scheiß rasierer aber
junge alter immer nicht mal richtig
zugemacht jetzt bin ich doch irgendwie
so ein bisschen gebremst in meiner
euphorie aber leute kein grund zur panik
ich nehme jetzt als neue zeitrechnung
ein bisschen unter mädchen steigen dann
schauen wir einfach machen leute was
geht ich habe jetzt mal alles
zusammengerechnet ich kommen insgesamt
auf 3200 euro ziel kam also das sind die
preise die im internet stehen klar werde
ich niemals bekommen viele sachen wenn
es die hälfte wird besser in ordnung
hätte mir ein bisschen mehr dennoch
erhofft davon trotzdem war es alles
andere als eine schlechte palette ich
weiß nicht wann ich doch im nachtrag ab
morgen wird es noch ins video eingebaut
ansonsten aber jetzt schon mal vielen
dank das zuschauen wenn ihr bock hofft
auf weitere packt das den vettel nach
oben läuft und wir sehen uns dann wieder
abonniert super gerne 30